Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.othered in the tower. Let us be laid within thy bosom, Richard, and weigh thee down to ruin, shame and death. Thy nephew's souls bid thee despair and die. That, um... I can barely speak after that out of terror uh because of course you told me that so welcome everybody to the rest of history we're doing this podcast about
感谢收听《The Rest Is History》。若想收听每周独家加更节目、无广告版本、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们广受欢迎的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.othered in the tower. Let us be laid within thy bosom, Richard, and weigh thee down to ruin, shame and death. Thy nephew's souls bid thee despair and die. That, um... I can barely speak after that out of terror uh because of course you told me that so welcome everybody to the rest is history we're doing this podcast about
princes in the tower tom holland has absolutely got me here under false pretenses because he told me that he was going to do a devastating impersonation of a creepy boy they were creepy boys i mean i defy anyone to listen to that and not be terrified scared out of their wits i can imagine even now that listeners are carrying behind the sofas or under their beds out of dread so that wet that was it wasn't it was terrifying it was despair hello birds hello sky despair and die
terrifying and they were of course the princes in the tower Edward V and his younger brother yeah
太吓人了，他们当然就是塔中王子，爱德华五世和他的弟弟。
Richard of Shrewsbury who in Shakespeare's play Richard III appeared to him on the eve of the Battle of Bosworth along with the ghosts of everybody else that Richardard has murdered uh and or or has he yes well in shakespeare's play he yes
理查德·肖斯布里。在莎士比亚的戏剧《理查三世》中，他在博斯沃思战役前夕出现在理查三世面前，一同出现的还有所有被理查德谋杀之人的鬼魂……呃，或者说，真的是这样吗？是的，好吧，在莎士比亚的戏剧里，确实如此。
he has i mean there's no question about that okay and they of course he has absolutely uh and um it's the uh actually the second quotation from uh rich the third that's featured in recent weeks because we also had one from Clarence's dream before Richard murders him by having him dunked in a butt of marmsy on Bart Van Loo's sensational episode about the Dukes of Burgundy so this is we've moved from Burgundy back to England and Dominic the question that we're asked well actually the theme is Princes in the Tower but of course there is the question which is what happened to them? Were they murdered? And if so, who murdered them?
他确实出现了，我是说，毫无疑问，是的，完全如此。呃，实际上，这是近几周播客中第二次出现《理查三世》的台词了，因为在巴特·范·洛（Bart Van Loo）关于勃艮第公爵的精彩单集里，理查德把克拉伦斯淹死在玛姆塞甜酒桶里谋杀他之前，也有过克拉伦斯梦境的台词。所以我们从勃艮第回到了英格兰。多米尼克，我们要探讨的问题是——实际上主题就是“塔中王子”，但当然这里有一个问题：他们究竟遭遇了什么？他们是被谋杀的吗？如果是的话，又是谁谋杀的呢？
It is the absolute greatest mystery in English history, isn't it? I mean, it's the one that everybody has heard of. It's the most romantic. It's the one that sort of amateur historians still try to solve. And obviously, well, we shouldn't give away our answer because we do have an answer, don't we? Collectively, I think we do. Is it fair to say that we've solved the mystery?
这绝对是英国历史上最大的谜团，不是吗？我的意思是，这是人尽皆知的一个，也是最具传奇色彩的一个，业余历史学家们至今仍在试图解开这个谜团。显而易见，嗯，我们不应该剧透我们的答案，因为我们确实有一个答案，不是吗？大家集思广益，我想我们确实有了答案。说我们已经解开了这个谜团，这算不算言之过早？
I think that might be going too far, but I think we have arrived at a consensus as to who we think did it. Yeah. And we should say that the focus is on, the title of this episode is Princes in the Tower rather than Richard III or Henry VII or whatever, because we thought that would be a kind of interesting angle. So, Dominic, the Princes in the Tower, let's look at the eldest of them, Edward, who becomes Edward V.
我想这可能有点过头了，但我认为我们已经就“究竟是谁干的”这一点达成了共识。是的。我们应该说明，本集的焦点——本集的标题是《塔中王子》，而不是《理查三世》或《亨利七世》之类——是因为我们觉得这是一个相当有趣的切入点。那么，多米尼克，关于塔中王子，让我们来看看他们当中年纪最大的那个，爱德华，他后来成了爱德华五世。
And he is born on the 2nd of November, 1470. And it's not the most propitious circumstances is it for him no he's born in so he's born at a place called Cheney Gates which is the house of the abbot of Westminster it's basically next to Westminster Abbey it's above the Croysteads isn't it I think yeah I think so and his mother so he is the son we're in yeah 1470 he is the son. We're in 1470. He is the son of King Edward IV and his wife, Elizabeth Woodville. But he is born in sanctuary because his father has currently fled and is effectively in exile in the latest twist of the colossal Game of Thrones inspiring saga that is the Wars of the Roses. Yes. And so his wife, his queen, Elizabeth Woodville,
他出生于1470年11月2日。对他来说，这并不是一个最吉利的时刻，对吧？不，他出生在……所以他出生在一个叫切尼门（Cheney Gates）的地方，那是威斯敏斯特修道院长的宅邸，基本上就在威斯敏斯特修道院旁边，在克罗伊斯特兹（Croysteds）上面，对吧？我想是的。他的母亲……所以他是……我们正处于……是的，1470年，他是……国王爱德华四世和他的妻子伊丽莎白·伍德维尔的儿子。但他出生在避难所里，因为他的父亲当时刚刚逃亡，实际上处于流亡状态，这是玫瑰战争这个宏大又堪称《权力的游戏》灵感源泉的传奇故事中的最新转折。是的。所以他的妻子，他的王后，伊丽莎白·伍德维尔，
has taken sanctuary there, as indeed she will do again subsequently. And we'll come to that. So there's a lot of people claiming sanctuary in this episode. But you mentioned Wars of the Roses. So let's look at Edward'sward's two parents edward the fourth and elizabeth woodville let's look at edward the fourth first so i mean he he has this kind of strange reign he he comes to power um and he rules and then he goes into exile and then he
在那里寻求了庇护，而且正如她后来还会再次做的那样。我们稍后会讲到这一点。所以在这一集里有很多人在寻求庇护。但你提到了玫瑰战争。所以让我们来看看爱德华的父母，爱德华四世和伊丽莎白·伍德维尔。让我们先来看看爱德华四世。我的意思是，他有一段非常奇怪的统治生涯，他掌权，统治，然后流亡，然后他又
comes back again and that's kind of unique really in the history of english kings so he is the son of someone who we mentioned in the 12 Days of Christmas episode, Richard of York, who gave battle in vain. Yes, in a way this is a kind of sequel to that, isn't it? Richard of York who died at the Battle of Wakefield and his head was put on the gates and crowned by Margaret of Anjou. So in a way our story picks up straight after that. So Richard of York is the Yorkist claimant
卷土重来，这在英国国王的历史上可以说是相当独特的。所以他是我们在《圣诞十二日》节目中提到过的人的儿子——理查 of 约克，他曾徒劳地发起战斗。是的，从某种意义上说，这可以说是那期节目的续集，不是吗？理查 of 约克在韦克菲尔德战役中战死，他的头颅被挂在城门上，并被安茹的玛格丽特戴上了王冠。所以从某种意义上说，我们的故事就从那之后紧接着展开。因此，理查 of 约克是约克家族对
to Henry VI's throne. So the English nobility is kind of divided between Lancastrians and Yorkists. And when Richard dies, his claim passes to his eldest son, who is Edward, Earl of March, I think it was before.
亨利六世王位的索取者。因此，英国贵族大致分为兰开斯特派和约克派。当理查去世时，他的王位继承权传给了他的长子，也就是之前的爱德华，马奇伯爵，我想是的。
Who is this, so he's 18 I think it was before, who is this. So he's 18 years old when his father dies. He is a scrapping lad. He is extremely, he is the grandfather of Henry VIII, isn't he? As it turns out. So if you listen to our Six Wives of Henry VIII podcast, he is very, very similar, actually. His trajectory is very similar to Henry VIII's, isn't it? You can definitely sort of see the genetic inheritance because he's huge.
这是谁，我记得他当时18岁，这是谁。所以他父亲去世时他18岁。他是一个好斗的小伙子。他极其……他后来成了亨利八世的外祖父，不是吗？事实证明正是如此。所以如果你听过我们的《亨利八世的六个妻子》播客，你就会发现他非常非常相似，实际上。他的轨迹和亨利八世非常相似，不是吗？你绝对可以看出那种基因遗传，因为他非常高大。
What is he, six foot four or something? Which is absolutely colossal by the time. I think we may have mentioned this before. I think when and if Prince William becomes king, he's the only king who will be taller than Edward IV. Is that right? I think so, yeah. May have got that wrong.
他有多高？六尺四寸左右吗？这在当时绝对是个庞然大物。我想我们以前可能提到过这一点。我想如果威廉王子将来成为国王，他将是唯一一个比爱德华四世更高的国王。是这样吗？我想是的，对。我也许记错了。
But Edward IV, everybody says he is a very, very impressive person. And he's a massive lad, isn't he? He is a massive lad. He likes his food, he likes his drink, and he likes his ladies. Yeah, absolutely. And he likes fighting, and he likes his ladies. Yeah, absolutely. And he likes fighting, and he's very good at fighting. He's the sort of model. He's an alpha male, as Henry VIII was when his grandson will be when he's young.
但关于爱德华四世，每个人都说他是一个非常非常令人印象深刻的人。而且他是个大块头，对吧？他确实是个大块头。他喜欢吃，喜欢喝，还喜欢美女。对，绝对的。而且他喜欢打仗，也很擅长打仗。他可以说是那种模范。他是那种阿尔法雄男，就像亨利八世年轻时那样，当他的孙子年轻时也会那样。
He's a sort of a roistering, slaughtering, hard-living, hard-drinking, womanising. He's basically the guy from the University Rugby Club. Yeah, womanising. He's basically the guy from the university rugby club. Yeah, he is. He's the president of the kind of college sports society and all that. Absolutely he is. And quite quickly after his father's death, he turns it all around.
他是个那种喧闹、嗜杀、纵情声色、酗酒、好色之徒。他基本上就是大学橄榄球队里的那个家伙。对，好色之徒。他基本上就是大学橄榄球队里的那个家伙。是的，他就是。他是那种大学体育社团的主席之类的人物。绝对是的。在他父亲去世后不久，他就迅速扭转了局势。
He wins a couple of battles, most famously the Battle of Towton, which is the bloodiest battle ever fought on English soil. And so by 1461, at the age of, basically by the time he's turned 19, he's on his way to becoming king, to kicking out the Lancastrians. What does he do? He captures Henry VI. And he doesn't kill him, does he?
他赢得了几场战役，其中最著名的是陶顿战役，这是英国本土上爆发过最血腥的战役。所以在1461年左右，在他基本上刚满19岁的时候，他就已经在通往国王的路上，在把兰开斯特派赶下台了。他做了什么？他俘虏了亨利六世。而且他没有杀他，对吧？
No. Because Marc de Vangeu and their son, again, What does he do? He captures Henry VI. And doesn't kill him, does he? No. Because. Which is interesting. Marc de Fonjou and their son, again, confusingly called Edward. I mean, basically everyone's called Edward in this episode. So many apologies. So let's call him the Lancastrian Edward. They've gone into exile. So there's no point in killing Henry VI.
不。因为安茹的玛格丽特和他们的儿子，同样令人困惑地也叫爱德华——我的意思是，基本上这一集里每个人都叫爱德华，非常抱歉，所以我们叫他兰开斯特的爱德华——他们已经流亡了。所以杀亨利六世毫无意义。
And in fact, he's a kind of an insurance policy because he's pretty delally by this point so he's locked up in the tower he's looked after quite well but he's kind of immured away and Edward sets about establishing the foundations of his regime it speaks well Fred would actually he doesn't kill him
事实上，他成了一种保险单，因为到这个时候他已经相当神志不清了，所以他被关在塔里，虽然被照顾得挺好，但基本上是被软禁了起来，而爱德华则着手奠定他政权的基础。其实这说明爱德华挺不错的，他没有杀他。
I don't think it does at all I think it's pure politics because in due course well of course he does kill him eventually yeah but I mean I think it does I think it's pure politics because in due course he does kill him eventually I think that's reasonable I think Edward is completely ruthless do you know who he looks like Tom
我可一点不这么认为。我认为这纯粹是出于政治考量，因为到头来——当然他最终还是把他杀了，对吧？但我的意思是，我认为是的，这纯粹是出于政治考量，因为到头来他确实把他杀了。我认为这很合理，爱德华是个极其冷酷无情的人。你知道他长得像谁吗，汤姆？
if you look at the portrait he has the face of David Cameron which you know there is something David Cameron-esque about him I mean he's ostensibly a kind of impressive figure. He wins, you know, he's very successful at winning things, but ultimately he becomes a terrible failure. I mean, I hope no spoilers there.
如果你看那幅肖像画，他有着一张大卫·卡梅伦的脸，你知道的，他身上确实有一种大卫·卡梅伦式的气质。我的意思是，表面上看他是一个相当令人印象深刻的人物。他赢了，你知道的，他在赢得胜利方面非常成功，但最终他却成了一个彻底的失败者。我是说，希望这不算剧透。
So Dave, if you're listening. No, I agree. Yeah, there is something of that kind of ruddy-cheeked, posh. Yeah. Yeah, I think there is. But I think that Edward IV is a very, very ruthless operator. I think if he has to kill people, he will. But he'll hug a husky first or whatever it is.
所以戴夫，如果你在听的话。不，我同意。是的，那种红光满面、有点上流社会的气质确实有点。对，对，我也这么觉得。但我认为爱德华四世是一个非常非常冷酷无情的操盘手。我认为如果他必须杀人，他会的。但在那之前他会先去抱抱哈士奇什么的。
All that kind of thing. Yeah, all that kind of thing. So he's ruling as a usurper, basically. And so his regime is inherently precarious. There are lots of people who wish him nothing but ill. And so he has to tread very, very carefully. And obviously, one of the things that a usurping king, fresh on the throne, has to do, and this is absolutely in the context of everything that Bart Van Loo was saying in with the episode on the Burgundians, is that there are a lot of
诸如此类的事情。是的，诸如此类的事情。所以他基本上是以一个篡位者的身份在统治。因此，他的政权天生就岌岌可危。有很多人对她恨之入骨、唯恐其不乱。所以他必须如履薄冰、小心翼翼。显然，一个刚登上王位的新篡位国王必须要做到的一点——这完全契合巴特·范·洛在勃艮第人那一集里所说的背景——那就是有很多
predatory foreign powers, as well as domestic enemies. And so the key thing that an eligible young bachelor on the freshly minted on the throne of England has to do is to marry advantageously and that means sourcing himself as a really top quality foreign bride well the thing is tom to go back to our bartleham van leu podcast england is is in this dance isn't it with france and burgundy so france and burgundy are the sort of two neighbouring powers and England is flitting between the two of them. And what makes it more complicated, this
虎视眈眈的外国列强，以及国内的敌人。因此，一个刚登上英国王位、正值适婚年龄的年轻单身汉必须要做的关键事情，就是进行一场有利的联姻，这意味着要为自己物色一位真正顶级的外国新娘。问题是，汤姆，回到我们的巴特·范·洛播客，英格兰正处于与法国和勃艮第的这场博弈中，不是吗？所以法国和勃艮第是两个邻近的强权，而英格兰则在两者之间摇摆不定。让这个
issue of the bride, is that Edward owes his ascendancy not just to his own sort of strappingness and his martial ability but to a very, very powerful patron or ally, which is the Richard Neville, Earl of Warwick, famously Warwick the Kingmaker. And Warwick is very keen to have an alliance with France.
新娘问题更加复杂的是，爱德华的上位不仅归功于他自己的英武强壮和军事才能，还归功于一个非常非常强大的赞助人或盟友，那就是里查德·内维尔，沃里克伯爵，也就是著名的“造王者”沃里克。而沃里克非常热衷于与法国结盟。
And he spends a lot of time, you know, once Edward is king and then Castron's been kicked out, he spends an enormous amount of time negotiating an alliance. It's very Henry VIII style. He spends an enormous amount of time in sort of thomas cromwell style enterprise of sorting out an alliance with the french and a marriage alliance and all the rest of it and investing a lot of his political capital in this very publicly and and and he warwick definitely thinks you know edward is a young man he's david cameron he's my puppet um It's very clear I am the power in England. And getting the alliance and the right marriage for his puppets obviously matters enormously to his sense of status and prestige, which is why... When the news reaches him, Edward, rather than going for a French bride or indeed any foreign bride, has married an English commoner.
他花了大量时间——你知道的，一旦爱德华成为国王，兰开斯特人被赶走后——他花了大把大把的时间来谈判结盟。这非常具有亨利八世的风格。他花了大量时间，以托马斯·克伦威尔式的企业作风，来敲定与法国人的联盟、联姻以及诸如此类的事情，并在其中投入了大量的政治资本，非常公开地这样做。而且沃里克绝对认为，你知道的，爱德华是个年轻人，他就是大卫·卡梅伦，他是我的傀儡。
And not just any commoner, but a woman who has already been married and has two sons already. And this, it cannot be overemphasized, is not how English kings are supposed to behave so I suppose you could say I mean isn't um so so the person he marries is uh a woman called Elizabeth Woodville and basically she's she's the kind of so Elizabeth Bowes Lowen bows low lion how do you bow's lion bow's lion the queen mother the queen mother who marries george the sixth she marries him when he is not expected to become king that's right yes um so really the only other um the person who's expected to become king who's married a commoner is again prince william who keeps popping up in this conversation so um kate middleton is you've met prince william that's presumably the reason why
很明显，我才是英格兰的权力核心。为他的傀儡争取联盟和合适的婚姻，显然对他的身份感和威望至关重要，正因如此……当消息传到他耳中时，爱德华没有去迎娶一位法国新娘，甚至没有选择任何外国新娘，而是娶了一个英国平民。
you keep bringing him up and you're both aston Aston Villa supporters. Yes, we had a chat. As is David Cameron, actually. That was back when Villa were beating Manchester United. The three of you should get together and do your own Rest Is History. Yeah, we should, shouldn't we? We get Nigel Kennedy and Tom Hanks along. That would be great. We could all bleed Claret and Blue together.
而且不仅是一个普通的平民，还是一个已经结过婚并且已经有两个儿子的女人。这一点，无论如何强调都不过分，根本不是英国国王应有的行为方式。所以我想你可以这么说——我的意思是，难道……所以他娶的人是一个叫伊丽莎白·伍德维尔的女人，基本上她就是那种……就像伊丽莎白·鲍斯-莱昂（Elizabeth Bowes-Lyon）——怎么发音来着？鲍斯-莱昂（Bowes-Lyon），王太后，嫁给乔治六世的那位王太后。她是在乔治六世没指望成为国王的时候嫁给他的，没错，是的。
Well, I think the parallel here. So I think the marriage to Elizabeth Woodville. But Dominic, I just mentioned that because I think it emphasises how weird this is. I agree with you completely, Tom. And I think the marriage to Elizabeth Woodville is in many ways the absolute most important foundation point for this whole story, for this podcast. It's a fracture point from which the entire structure will kind of disintegrate. It's so unusual unusual as you say clearly what's happened is that edward has been uh has has he is motivated by and he's infatuated with elizabeth woodville and i think
所以实际上，唯一一个……那个被寄予厚望成为国王却娶了个平民的人，又是威廉王子，他在这段对话中不断出现。所以……凯特·米德尔顿……你见过威廉王子，这大概就是你不断提起他的原因，而且你们俩都是阿斯顿维拉球迷。是的，我们聊过。大卫·卡梅伦其实也是。那是维拉击败曼联的时候。你们三个应该聚在一起搞你们自己的《The Rest Is History》播客。
what is so fascinating about this whole story but you know what tom what's you the last time you did that impersonation full force was in our six wives of him the eighth podcast yeah and i think what's so interesting about this entire story about the marriage to elizabeth woodville about the succession of a very of a young boy as king is is the parallels with what happens a generation it's a marriage isn't it marriage is absolutely like the heart of this whole story because the elizabeth woodville is not unlike anne boleyn in that she refuses to be, she basically will not be the king's mistress. Edward has a lot of mistresses, but she wants a marriage. So he marries her.
是的，我们应该这么做，对吧？我们可以把奈杰尔·肯尼迪和汤姆·汉克斯也请来。那太棒了。我们可以一起为红蓝军团摇旗呐喊。好吧，我认为这里的平行之处在于——所以我认为与伊丽莎白·伍德维尔的婚姻……但是多米尼克，我之所以提到这一点，是因为我认为它强调了这件事有多么离奇。我完全同意你的看法，汤姆。我认为与伊丽莎白·伍德维尔的婚姻在许多方面是整个故事、整个播客绝对最重要的基石。这是一个断裂点，整个结构将从这里开始瓦解。它太不寻常了，正如你所说，很明显发生的事情是爱德华受到了伊丽莎白·伍德维尔的吸引并对她神魂颠倒，而我认为
And that's the point at which, as in the sagas of Henry VIII with the Boleyns and the Seymours and so on, she brings her family because that's what you do. Well, hold on. So let's look at her family. So who is Elizabeth Woodville? Her mother is actually quite classy, isn't she? She's a jaqueta. That's right.
整个故事最迷人的是……你知道吗，汤姆，你上次全力模仿那个声音还是在我们的《亨利八世的六个妻子》播客里。是的，而我认为关于伊丽莎白·伍德维尔的婚姻、关于一个非常年轻的男孩作为国王的继位，整个故事最有趣的是与几代人之后发生的事情的相似之处……婚姻，不是吗？婚姻绝对是整个故事的核心，因为伊丽莎白·伍德维尔与安妮·博林有相似之处，她拒绝成为国王的情妇。爱德华有很多情妇，但她想要的是婚姻。所以他娶了她。
Claims descent from Charlemagne, related to Bart Van Loo's Dukes of Burgundy. And she had actually, she'd had a good marriage. She'd married the brother of Henry V, John the Duke of Bedford. But then he dies and she then marries a guy called Richard Woodfill, who's basically an elite sportsman. He's common, but he's an elite sportsman. He's a great, great jouster. A bit like me, I suppose. But he's basically, I mean, he's not, I mean, even by the standards of the English. He's not an ability. Yeah. So even by the standards of English snobbery, he's kind of quite low down the social scale.
这就是转折点，正如亨利八世与博林家族、西摩家族等人的传奇故事一样，她把她的家族带了进来，因为这就是你会做的事。好吧，等等。让我们来看看她的家族。伊丽莎白·伍德维尔是谁？她的母亲其实相当有档次，不是吗？她叫杰奎塔（Jaquetta）。没错。
And really, I suppose that, you know, kind of the intriguing parallel is Catherine of Valois, who had married Henry V, who then marries Owen Tudor. Yes, he drops down a bit of a few levels. So kind of similar thing. So anyway, so Jaquetta marries this guy, Richard Woodville, who is a tremendous jouster. And he becomes Lord Rivers. He fights at the Battle of Towton against Edward IV, but his partner. Yeah, they're Lancastrians, aren't they, originally? Yeah. And so Elizabeth, his daughter, she is also married to a Lancastrian,
声称自己是查理曼大帝的后代，与巴特·范·洛的勃艮第公爵有亲戚关系。她其实有过一段不错的婚姻。她嫁给了亨利五世的弟弟，贝德福德公爵约翰。但后来他死了，于是她又嫁给了一个叫理查·伍德维尔的人，他基本上是个精英运动员。他出身平民，但他是个精英运动员。他是个很厉害很厉害的比武骑士。有点像我，我猜。但他基本上——我的意思是，他不是——甚至以英国的标准来看，他也
Sir John Gray, who had died at the Battle of St. Albans in 1461. So back in the Richard of York days. They've got two children. And she's basically, she has a kind of predatory mother-in-law, doesn't she? And she decides to to appeal to the king and she does that in the full knowledge that basically you know she's um that that she has attributes that will appeal to the king well she's 28 he's what is he 22 i think so she's a milf I believe oh god I can't believe you've gone there Tom oh well um anyway yes well I think Edward IV is you know just to reiterate he is a massive lad who allows his libido to lead him yeah and she plays her cards very I mean she plays her cards as Anne Boleyn
社会阶层相当低下。真的，我想，你知道，其中一个有趣的平行人物是瓦卢瓦的凯瑟琳，她嫁给了亨利五世，后来又嫁给了欧文·都铎。是的，阶层确实往下掉了一点。所以有点类似的事情。总之，杰奎塔嫁给了这个叫理查·伍德维尔的家伙，他是一个了不起的比武骑士。他成了里弗斯勋爵。他在陶顿战役中与爱德华四世作对，但后来成了同盟。是的，他们原本是兰开斯特派，对吧？是的。所以他的女儿伊丽莎白，她也曾嫁给一个兰开斯特派的人，
Duds a generation later she basically no, I have to marry you. That's the deal. He's like, great, let's do it. And when Warwick hears the news, Warwick is absolutely furious because Edward has thrown away the chance of the marriage alliance. He's made Warwick look like an idiot. But also what's happened is that by introducing the Woodville family, because she brings with her inevitably her brothers her father the this kind of uh
也就是约翰·格雷爵士，他在1461年的圣阿尔班斯战役中阵亡了。也就是理查 of 约克的时代。他们有两个孩子。而且她基本上有一个……有一个掠夺成性的婆婆，不是吗？她决定向国王申诉，而她这么做时十分清楚地知道，基本上，你知道，她……她拥有能够吸引国王的特质。嗯，她28岁，他……他多大？22岁，我想。所以她是个熟女（milf），我相信。噢天哪，真不敢相信你竟然说出这个，汤姆。哦，好吧……总之，是的，我想爱德华四世——重申一下，他是个大块头，由着自己的俄狄浦斯情结（应为libido，色欲）支配——是的，而且她把牌打得很好……我的意思是，她打牌的技巧就像
it's all about networks isn't it medieval politics it's all about patronage networks she brings in this whole load of people who are going to need offices and lands and everything and they upset the balance and actually that's the what are we 1464 so 20 for 20 years that balance is basically upset that's's, that's absolutely true. But, but just to stick up for Elizabeth Woodville, she, I think she's an incredibly impressive figure.
一代人之后的安妮·博林一样。她基本上就是：不，我必须嫁给你。这就是条件。他大概是：太棒了，那就这么办。当沃里克听到这个消息时，沃里克气急败坏，因为爱德华扔掉了联姻的机会。他把沃里克当成了白痴。但同时发生的事情是，通过引入伍德维尔家族——因为她不可避免地带来了她的兄弟们、她的父亲、这种……
Oh, I'm not knocking her. I mean, she plays very cleverly. I think she, she's a superb queen. So I think the whole thing, so,
中世纪政治全都是关于关系的，不是吗？全都是关于裙带关系网络的。她带来了这一大群需要官职、土地以及一切的人，他们打破了权力的平衡。实际上，从——我们是在1464年吗？——到20年间，这种平衡基本上都被打破了。那……那是绝对真实的。但是，为了给伊丽莎白·伍德维尔说句公道话，她，我认为她是一个极其令人印象深刻的人物。
so she and Edward get married on May day, which is, you know, the romantic day par excellence. This is the age when Mallory is writing the Mort Darthur. There's the great romantic narratives of knights falling in love with ladies. And I think that that provides a kind of context that Edward will absolutely use. But Elizabeth does as well.
哦，我可不是在贬低她。我的意思是，她手段非常高明。我认为她是一个极好的王后。所以整件事……
She's very, very good at playing the gracious queen. Yeah, she plays the part very... The people who don't like her are their factional rivals. They don't necessarily censor the public. Absolutely. They've turned against her. But Elizabeth herself is very alert to basically how impoverished her husband's court is. He's a massive spendthrift.
所以她和爱德华在五一节结婚了，这是一个堪称完美的浪漫日子。这是马洛里正在撰写《亚瑟王之死》的时代。那是骑士爱上贵妇的伟大浪漫叙事盛行的时代。我认为这提供了一种爱德华绝对会利用的背景。但伊丽莎白也一样。
I mean, obviously, he's exactly the kind of guy who blows enormous quantities of money on all kinds of stuff. Doublets. Pies. So Elizabeth Woodville recognizes that she has to look like a queen. So she's very, very happy to spend money on looking like a queen. But otherwise, she makes economies. You're right, of course. It's the problem that she brings all these kind of relatives that is the issue but she does bring um one particularly i think tremendously
她非常非常擅长扮演温婉优雅的王后。是的，她把这个角色演得非常……不喜欢她的人是他们的派系政敌。他们不一定代表公众。绝对是的。他们已经背叛了她。但伊丽莎白本人对她丈夫的宫廷有多么穷困潦倒保持着高度的警惕。他是个挥金如土的大手大脚的人。
cool relative who's her brother anthony woodville who in due course will become well he's he's very clever isn't he's a great scholar and so on but again also a great sportsman so he's a patron of caxton you know who sets up yeah the first printing press and he's actually translated a whole compendium of sayings of philosophers from the French that is one of the very first books that Caxton publishes. But he also has this tremendous duel with a guy called the Bastard of Burgundy.
我的意思是，很明显，他就是那种把巨额资金花在各种各样东西上的人。双t恤（Doublets）。馅饼。所以伊丽莎白·伍德维尔意识到她必须看起来像个王后。所以她非常非常乐意把钱花在让自己看起来像个王后上。但除此之外，她一直在节约开支。你是对的，当然。问题在于她带来了所有这些亲戚，这才是症结所在，但她确实带来了一个……我认为特别酷的亲戚，那就是她的兄弟安东尼·伍德维尔。他后来将成为……他非常聪明，对吧？是个伟大的学者等等，但同时也是个伟大的运动员。所以他是卡克斯顿的赞助人，你知道的，卡克斯顿建立了英国第一家印刷厂。而且他实际上还从法文翻译了一部哲学家名言集，这是卡克斯顿出版的最早的书籍之一。但他还与一个名叫勃艮第私生子的人进行了一场惊心动魄的决斗。
Do you know about this? Oh, yes, I did. Yeah, it's in Bart Van Loo's book. It's in Thomas Penn's book, The Brothers York as well. Yes, and, I did. Yeah, it's in Bart Van Loo's book. It's in Thomas Penn's book, The Brothers York, as well. Yes, and that as well. They spent about 300 pages organising this massive tournament. So the bastard of Burgundy, which comes no surprise to anyone who's heard the episode on the Burgundians,
你知道这事吗？哦，是的，我知道。是的，它在巴特·范·洛的书里。它也在托马斯·佩恩的书《约克兄弟》里。是的，还有那个。他们花了大约300页的篇幅来组织这场盛大的比武大会。所以勃艮第的私生子，正如听过勃艮第那一集的人所料，
is the son of Philip, the good of Burgundy, who, as Bart reminded us, tended to get bastard every time he went on his travels. And, yeah, they set up this kind of incredible showcase of jousting. Because these are the two, you know, the bastard of Antoine, the bastard of Burgundy is the greatest jouster in Burgundy. And Anthony Woodville has a reputation as the greatest jouster in Englandland and they have this kind of two-day combat in london um where basically anthony woodville wins i mean edward has to kind of step in and stop it and he's very very cool and he's
他是勃艮第公爵“好人”菲利普的儿子。正如巴特提醒我们的那样，菲利普每次外出旅行都会留下私生子。而且，是的，他们举办了一场令人难以置信的比武展示。因为这两位——你知道的，安东尼的私生子、勃艮第的私生子安托万是勃艮第最伟大的比武骑士，而安东尼·伍德维尔在英国享有最伟大比武骑士的美誉。他们在伦敦进行了一场为期两天的决斗，基本上是安东尼·伍德维尔赢了。我的意思是，爱德华不得不介入并制止了它。而且他非常非常酷，在他……
on his um his uh his tent he has this phrase la nonchalance so he's a he's a kind of he's a very cool guy that's very cameroon, isn't it? To pursue the David Cameron analogy. Oh, come on. No, I think he's a kind of laid back, mellow, smart sportsman. But the thing though, Tom, is that he, okay, he is very, he's very impressive. He's very clever.
在他的帐篷上，他写下了这样一句话：“La nonchalance”（泰然处之）。所以他是个……他是个很酷的人。这非常“卡梅伦”，不是吗？借用一下大卫·卡梅伦的比喻。噢，拜托。不，我觉得他是个那种轻松、随和、聪明的运动员。但问题是，汤姆，他——好吧，他非常……他非常令人印象深刻。他非常聪明。
He's very, you know, he's very cultivated and all the rest of it. But because he's from the Parvenu family, that stuff makes enemies. And the thing is, being a medieval king is all about, you don't have absolute power or anything like it. What you have is this very complicated machine and these incredibly convoluted and elaborate and intricate networks of kind of regional loyalties absolutely and associations and you upset that at your peril you know you need to keep that machine ticking along and basically divvying out the rewards the
他非常……你知道的，他非常有教养等等。但正因为他来自暴发户家族，这种作风树敌众多。而且关键在于，作为一个中世纪的国王，这一切的根本在于，你并不拥有绝对权力或类似的东西。你拥有的是一台非常复杂的机器，以及这些极其错综复杂、繁复精细的区域忠诚网络。
offices the lands and making sure that everybody's happy want and and you know i mean you can go down one route and basically pick a side kill the others or whatever but then you have to do it really ruthlessly otherwise you have to keep things in balance and you could argue that I mean we had quite a few questions about this is Edward IV
绝对的，还有各种联盟。如果你去打破这种平衡，那就是自寻死路。你需要让这台机器顺畅运转，基本上就是分发奖赏、官职、土地，确保每个人都开心。而且，你知道的——我的意思是，你可以走另一条路，基本上就是选定一方，杀光其他人，诸如此类。但那样的话，你必须做得非常冷酷无情，否则你就必须维持各方的平衡。你可以说——我们收到了不少关于这方面的提问——爱德华四世是一个失败者吗？因为他基本上让这个系统失去了平衡。我的意思是，我想我会这样说——
a failure because he basically allows the system to get out of balance I mean I suppose I would argue Yeah so Peter Davies could you outline Edward IV false failures in allowing such factionalism to lead to regicide the king who never lost a battle but lost the war i think wouldn't you say tom that such factionalism is inherent in the system you're always going to have different factions and keeping them in balance i mean edward keeps them in balance actually well quite well he makes one very big mistake which in 14 what is it 14 70 71 doesn't he when the facts
是的，彼得·戴维斯（Peter Davies）问：你能否概述一下爱德华四世在允许这种派系主义导致弑君方面的失败？这个从未输过一场战役却输掉了整场战争的国王。汤姆，难道你不认为这种派系主义是该系统固有的吗？你总会有不同的派系，而维持它们的平衡——我的意思是，爱德华实际上把平衡维持得相当好。他犯了一个非常大的错误，在14，那是哪一年？1470到1471年，不是吗？当时各派系
get completely out of balance which is which is the backdrop for for why his son the future of the fifth has to be born in sanctuary and perhaps we should um come to that after a break okay i'm marina hyde and i'm richard osmond and together we host the rest is entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club.
彻底失衡，而这正是他的儿子、未来的爱德华五世不得不在避难所出生的背景。也许我们应该在休息之后再来探讨这个。好了，我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde），我是理查·奥斯曼（Richard Osman），我们共同主持《The Rest Is Entertainment》。这是你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、八卦爆料，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。
If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com Welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are proceeding at a somewhat glacial pace towards the story of the princes in the tower. So we're just approaching the moment where the first prince is going to be born.
如果你想享受无广告收听、独家加更节目以及抢先购买现场门票的福利，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《The Rest Is History》。我们正以一种略显冰川般的速度推进塔中王子的故事。所以我们正接近第一位王子出生的时刻。
That's Edward V. So, Tom, we ended the just before the break i'm talking about edward iv and factionalism and obviously edward iv is going to he's in for a shock because he's offended the earl of warwick by marrying elizabeth woodville and this is about to it's basically about to blow up in his face in In 1469, I think, you have the first real signs that the Earl of Warwick has basically allied with Edward's brother, George,
也就是爱德华五世。所以，汤姆，我们在中场休息前结束了关于爱德华四世和派系主义的话题。显然爱德华四世要……他要大吃一惊了，因为他通过娶伊丽莎白·伍德维尔冒犯了沃里克伯爵，而这即将……这基本上要在他的脸上炸开。在1469年，我想，你看到了沃里克伯爵基本上与爱德华的弟弟乔治结盟的第一真正迹象，
who is the Duke of Clarence. And George and Warwick feel very aggrieved at the intrusion of the Woodvilles into the kind of factional machine. And they're starting to get very restive and you start to get this sense that there's a great cataclysm coming.
也就是克拉伦斯公爵。乔治和沃里克对伍德维尔家族闯入这种派系机器感到非常不满。他们开始变得焦躁不安，你开始感觉到一场巨大的灾难即将来临。
And then it does come, doesn't it? In 1470, yes. Where Warwick basically changes sides, unbelievably having been... As also does Clarence. False, fleeting, perjured Clarence, as Shakespeare has said, has it. So Warwick's treachery is, I mean, kind of understandable because Edward has basically shafted him with this marriage in all kinds of ways.
然后灾难真的降临了，不是吗？在1470年，是的。沃里克竟然不可思议地叛变了，从……克拉伦斯也是如此。“虚伪、多变、背信弃弃义的克拉伦斯”，正如莎士比亚所说的那样。所以沃里克的背叛——我的意思是，某种程度上是可以理解的，因为爱德华在各方面都用这场婚姻坑了他。
Clarence, I think, is less forgivable. But anyway, so Edward, to his astonishment, I mean, it all kind of just melts away incredibly fast. And Edward basically finds that he, despite being king for basically a decade and actually playing the role of king quite well, he's not very popular. Support melts away.
至于克拉伦斯，我认为就更难原谅了。总之，爱德华大惊失色——我的意思是，这一切都以极其惊人的速度土崩瓦解。爱德华基本上发现，尽管他当了大约十年的国王，而且把国王的角色扮演得相当不错，但他并不是很受欢迎。支持率迅速瓦解。
And he and his youngest brother so there are three brothers edward the fourth george duke of clarence who has sided with warwick and the younger brother richard who become duke of gloucester in fact is he duke of gloucester by this point i can't remember so so richard who is who is the youngest brother doesn't betray Edward, sticks with him. And together they flee England and they go to Burgundy where Edward's sister, Margaret, has married Charles the Bold. That's right. Again, listeners may remember from the Burgundians. It's a place against the backdrop of this Franco-Burgundian rivalry.
他和他的小弟弟——所以有三个兄弟：爱德华四世、与沃里克结盟的克拉伦斯公爵乔治，以及后来成为格洛斯特公爵的小弟弟理查——事实上，他这时候已经是格洛斯特公爵了吗？我不记得了。所以理查，也就是最小的弟弟，没有背叛爱德华，一直追随着他。他们一起逃离英格兰，前往勃艮第，在那里爱德华的姐姐玛格丽特嫁给了大胆查理。没错。同样，听众们也许还记得勃艮第那一集。这是一个以这种法勃争端为背景的地方。
So the French are backing a Lancastrian restoration with the Earl of Warwick, and the Burgundians are basically offering Edward IV and his brother Richard sanctuary in time to kind of rebuild their forces. So England is basically prey, to some extent, to the sort of great power ambitions of France and Burgundy, isn't it? Yeah, absolutely. And it's with Burgundian support that Edward and Richard are able to return to occupy London. There's a terrible battle that is fought in Barnet in north london in this in the
因此，法国人支持由沃里克伯爵发起的兰开斯特王朝复辟，而勃艮第人则基本上为爱德华四世和他的弟弟理查提供避难所，让他们有时间重建军队。所以英格兰在某种程度上基本上成了法国和勃艮第争夺大国雄心的牺牲品，不是吗？是的，绝对是的。正是在勃艮第的支持下，爱德华和理查才得以返回并占领伦敦。在伦敦北部巴尼特的
fog heavy fog in the fog um richard um outflanks warwick there um there's great slaughter warwick is killed well warwick is very you know tom i i loved warwick the kingmaker when i was a teenager when i was kind of well we're going as kind of 11 or 12 when we did this at school i was a very passionate admirer of warwick the Kingmaker, and I've always felt he was very unlucky because don't his soldiers mistake some of their allies in the fog for Yorkists, and they open fire on them, and it all goes horribly wrong,
浓雾中，爆发了一场可怕的战斗。在浓雾中，理查在巴尼特迂回到沃里克侧翼……那里发生了大屠杀，沃里克被杀了。噢，沃里克，你知道吗，汤姆，我十几岁的时候——大概十一岁或十二岁，我们在学校学到这个的时候——我非常崇拜“造王者”沃里克，我一直觉得他非常倒霉，因为难道不是他的士兵在浓雾中把一些盟友误认成了约克派，然后向他们开火，结果一切都变得一团糟，
and Warwick is kind of butchered by Yorkist soldiers. To me, it always seemed a great tragedy that this very impressive magnate had such a... And how do you feel now you're less less of a fan i don't i don't i don't care um i don't well i mean they're all they're all brutal and horrible yeah they're all exactly exactly yeah but there's kind of horrible stories of people back in london waiting for news and people start drifting back and they've kind of lost their noses and you know oh god eyes and kind of horrible details that That's medieval battles for you, Tom.
沃里克被约克派士兵给残酷杀害了吗？在我看来，这位令人印象深刻的显贵竟然落得如此下场，一直是个巨大的悲剧……那你现在觉得呢，你没那么崇拜他了吗？我……我不在乎，我……我才不在乎呢。好吧，我的意思是，他们都一样残暴，都一样可怕。是的，他们全都是……完全如此。但这里面有一些可怕的故事，讲的是伦敦的人们在等待消息，人们开始三三两两地返回，他们的鼻子都被割掉了，你知道的——天哪！——眼睛也没了，还有各种可怕的细节……这就是中世纪的战争，汤姆。
It's medieval battles for you, yeah. Don't get involved if you want to keep your nose. So that's what... And by this point, also, we should say that Clarence has again switched sides and has been reconciled with Edward. He's very much, I think it's fair to say, not a friend of the show. Well, yeah.
这就是中世纪的战争，没错。如果你想保住鼻子，就别卷入其中。这就是……到这个时候，我们还应该说，克拉伦斯再次叛变，与爱德华和解了。我认为可以公平地说，他绝对不是本节目的朋友。好吧，是的。
I don't think you want Clarence as your friend. Because you know he'd stab you in the back at some point. He definitely would. Well, he's permanently aggrieved, isn't he? Yes. I mean, he really is the sort of... The middle son. He has a terrible sense of entitlement and of victimhood,
我想你不会想让克拉伦斯当你的朋友的。因为你知道他随时会在背后捅你一刀。他绝对会的。好吧，他是个永远满腹牢骚的人，不是吗？是的。我的意思是，他真的是那种……中间的儿子。他有一种强烈的受之无愧感和受害者情结，
and everybody's against him. He's like the one in The Godfather. He's Fredo. He's Fredo. He's actually the classic middle brother, as I think Fredo is. Yeah. Yes, I think heo is I wonder if that was kind of inspiration as well because it's all there in Shakespeare Al Pacino kissing Fredo
每个人都在针对他。他就像《教父》里的那个角色。他是弗雷多（Fredo）。他就是弗雷多。他其实是典型的中间老二，我想弗雷多也是。是的，我想弗雷多确实是。我不知道这是否也是一种灵感来源，因为一切都在莎士比亚里。阿尔·帕西诺亲吻弗雷多……
Al Pacino made a whole film about Richard III so who knows looking for Richard it all connects get Al Pacino on your Aston Villa podcast with Cameron and Prince William dynamite so that's Warwick knocked out of the way but there's still the issue of margaret vanjou and um her son edward who she sees as the prince of wales and they need to be
阿尔·帕西诺拍了一整部关于《理查三世》的电影，所以谁知道呢？《寻找理查》。这一切都是连在一起的。把阿尔·帕西诺请到你们和卡梅伦、威廉王子一起的阿斯顿维拉播客里去吧，那绝对是个重磅炸弹。所以，沃里克被解决掉了，但仍然存在安茹的玛格丽特和她的儿子爱德华的问题，在玛格丽特看来，他才是威尔士亲王，他们必须
got rid of and edward goes storming off um and they kind of shadow each other up and down uh the line of uh the seven um and they they finally meet at Tewksbury yeah and there is a bloodbath absolute bloodbath and um Edward the Prince of Wales is killed Robert of Anjou flees and this is when Henry VI is finally dispatched in the tower. Yeah. Now, we mentioned that in the first half. I think it's kind of shocking that Henry VI, who has lost his mind and just a sort of doddering, sort of doted that he's killed. But it completely makes sense that Edward IV does this
被除掉。爱德华气势汹汹地出发了，双方在塞文河沿岸互相追踪。最后他们在蒂克斯伯里（Tewkesbury）相遇，是的。爆发了一场血流成河的大屠杀，绝对的血流成河。威尔士亲王爱德华被杀，安茹的玛格丽特逃亡。正是在这个时候，亨利六世终于在塔中被处决了。是的。现在，我们在上半场提到过这一点。我认为亨利六世已经疯了，只是个头脑昏庸、老态龙钟的糊涂虫，却被杀掉了，这挺令人震惊的。但爱德华四世这样做完全合情合理，
because Henry VI is a focus for opposition. You know, the Lancastrians have had one comeback attempt that has failed. It sort of makes sense that Edward IV now gives the order. Basically, as soon as the Battle of Shakespeare is over, okay, get rid of Henry VI. So in Shakespeare's play Henry VI
因为亨利六世是反对派的核心。你知道的，兰开斯特派已经有过一次失败的复辟尝试了。爱德华四世现在下达这个命令，完全说得通。基本上，莎士比亚战役（应为Tewkesbury战役，蒂克斯伯里战役）一结束，好，除掉亨利六世。所以在莎士比亚的戏剧《亨利六世》
Part 3, it's Richard who does it. It's Richard who murders him. There's absolutely no evidence whatsoever for that. Well, there is. Richard is said to have been present in the tower of london when henry is killed uh but the tower of london is a is a major of course it's a major complex yes it's the major kind of complex in london so of course of course there are probably lots of people present in the tower yes but then he is the son you know he is the the uh the the youngest and most trusted brother of the king,
第三部中，是理查干的。是理查谋杀了。但对此绝对没有任何证据。好吧，有的。据说当亨利被杀时，理查就在伦敦塔内。不过，伦敦塔是一个大型的……当然，它是一个大型综合建筑群，是的。它是伦敦主要的那种综合建筑群，所以当然……当然塔里可能有很多在场的人。是的，但他是国王的儿子，你知道的，他是……是最年轻、最受国王信任的弟弟，
I would have thought he probably was complicit in the murder of Henry VI. But there is no question that the order came from Edward IV. And there's no specific reason to think that, apart from later Tudor propaganda and Shakespeare, to think that Richard wasn't... I mean, it's perfectly plausible. I think there is.
我想他很可能参与了谋杀亨利六世。但毫无疑问，命令是爱德华四世下达的。除了后来的都铎王朝宣传和莎士比亚的剧作之外，没有任何具体理由认为理查没有……我的意思是，这完全是合情合理的。我认为是的。
Of course there is. Of course there is. Richard is Edward's trusted younger brother and he's present in the tower when Henry VI is killed. It's a major, major decision. It's a major policy step. I think Richard absolutely
当然有。当然有。理查是爱德华备受信任的幼弟，当亨利六世被杀时他就在塔里。这是一个重大得不能再重大的决定。这是一步重大的政治棋。我认为理查绝对
would have been complicit in it. But I don't think the idea that you get in Shakespeare that Richard comes galloping back from the Battle of Tewkesbury, kind of cackling and limping and dragging his hunchback and murders him just for the fun of it. I don't buy that kind of model of Richard as a villain, but I do buy the idea of Richard as a villain. But I do buy the idea of Richard as a ruthless henchman
参与其中了。但我不认为像莎士比亚剧中所展现的那样，理查从蒂克斯伯里战役骑马狂奔回来，一边咯咯怪笑、一瘸一拐地拖着驼背，纯粹为了好玩而谋杀了他。我不会买账那种把理查塑造成恶魔的模型，但我确实相信理查是一个冷酷无情国王的冷酷无情的心腹，因为那本就是一个冷酷无情的时代。这就是我愿意和你各退一步、各打五十大板的地方，汤姆。我会说，如果理查想成为这个政权的一部分——他当时18岁——如果他想成为他兄长政权的一部分（显然他想），那么他显然参与了爱德华四世所做出的决定。
of a ruthless king, because it's a ruthless age. Here's where I'd meet you halfway, Tom. I would say, if Richard wants to be part of the regime, he's 18 years old, if he wants to be part of his brother's regime, and obviously he does, then clearly he's complicit in the decisions taken by Edward IV,
残暴国王的残暴，因为这是一个残暴的时代。汤姆，这是我能对你做出妥协的地方。我会说，如果理查德想要成为政权的一部分，他今年18岁，如果他想成为他哥哥政权的一部分——显然他确实想——那么很显然，他必然是爱德华四世所做决策的同谋，
as are all the other Yorkists. Yes. I mean, basically, all the Yorkist elite must know that Henry VI is about to be rubbed out. They think it's reasonable. They fought this long war. It's madness to keep him on as a sort of focus for opposition, get rid of him.
约克家族的其他人也一样。是的。我的意思是，基本上，所有约克家族的上层都知道亨利六世快要被做掉了。他们觉得这很合理。他们打了这么久的仗。留着他作为某种反对派的焦点简直是疯了，干掉他吧。
The idea that Richard would have personally carried it out seems to me implausible. I'm not saying he personally killed him, but that he may well have had a kind of supervisory role. And the reason that I think that actually Richard's role is probably greater than that of, say, other Yorkist henchmen, is that Richard becomes Edward's, you know, is Edward's most trusted partner in rule.
理查德会亲自去执行这个想法，在我看来似乎不太可能。我不是说他亲手杀了理查德，但他很可能承担了某种监督的角色。我认为理查德的角色实际上可能比其他约克家族的心腹更大的原因是，理查德成为了爱德华的——你知道的，是爱德华统治时期最信任的伙伴。
But he becomes his most trusted partner because he went into exile with him. Absolutely. Because he's a blood relative. Yes, absolutely. He doesn't need to have killed Henry VI for that to be. I think it's improbable that he wouldn't have done. I mean, it's a key.
但他成为他最信任的伙伴，是因为他曾和他一起流亡。完全正确。因为他是血亲。是的，绝对是的。他不需要为了达成这一点去杀掉亨利六世。我觉得他不这么做的可能性很小。我的意思是，这是一个关键。
Should we just talk a tiny bit about richard at this point so he's 18 years old what we know about him is that he is he is small slight he probably has scoliosis um not a massive hunchback or anything like that but he's he definitely is not he's not so sort of to use a shakespearean word kind of misshapen that he can't fight in battle and be a very effective warrior. He's very serious. He's very pious. He has all these religious books that he annotates
我们是不是应该在这个时候稍微聊一下理查德？他当时18岁，我们对他的了解是，他身材矮小、瘦弱，可能患有脊柱侧弯，嗯，不是那种巨大的驼背之类的，但他绝对不是，他没有那种用莎士比亚的话说畸形到不能上战场打仗、不能成为一个非常高效的勇士的程度。他非常严肃。他非常虔诚。他有所有这些他会做批注的宗教书籍
kind of almost obsessively. He spends a lot of time in the north. So he's effectively a northerner. Well, he becomes it, doesn't he? Because when Edward gets back on the throne, he sent, so Clarence and Richard have both married daughters of Warwick. Which has created a lot of bad blood,
几乎带有强迫症。他在北方待了很长时间。所以他实际上是个北方人。嗯，他后来变成了北方人，不是吗？因为当爱德华重新登上王位时，他被派往……所以克拉伦斯和理查德都娶了沃 Warwick 的女儿。这造成了很多积怨，
hasn't he? Because Clarence didn't want Richard to marry a Warwick daughter because he knew it would mean sharing the great Warwick, the Neville inheritance. And so there is again, a kind of fracture point there which edward solves by basically giving clarence um you know a great chunk of lands including warwick's lands in the midlands and richard gets installed as um effectively the ruler of the north yeah and richard is much more effective than Clarence. And Clarence ends up, notoriously, he gets put in the tower. And as in the Shakespeare, the version of the Shakespeare play is that he gets drowned in a butt of Malmsey.
不是吗？因为克拉伦斯不想让理查德娶沃里克的一个女儿，因为他知道这意味着要分享伟大的沃里克——内维尔家族的遗产。所以这里又出现了一个裂痕，爱德华通过基本上给克拉伦斯——嗯，你知道的——一大片土地来解决这个问题，其中包括沃里克在米德兰兹的土地，而理查德则被安插为——嗯，实际上是北方的统治者。是的，理查德比克拉伦斯高效得多。而克拉伦斯最终，众所周知，他被关进了塔楼。就像莎士比亚戏剧版本里演的那样，他被淹死在了一桶马姆齐甜酒里。
He gets dispatched. But Richard proves himself a loyal and able servant. Do you know what Malmsey is? It's a kind of wine, isn't it? Do you know where it comes from? Malmsbury. No. No, I don't.
他被做掉了。但理查德证明了自己是一个忠诚且能干的仆人。你知道什么是马姆齐甜酒吗？那是一种酒，对吧？你知道它产自哪里吗？马姆斯伯里。不是。不，我不知道。
No. I thought it was Malmsbury. Malmsbury. It comes from Monemvasia. Oh, of course it does. Yes, in the Peloponnese. Yeah. Yes, of course.
不。我以为那是马姆斯伯里。马姆斯伯里。它产自莫奈姆瓦西亚。哦，当然是的！是的，在伯罗奔尼撒半岛。对。是的，当然。
I went to Monemvasia on holiday this summer, last summer. Did you taste carrots? We bought a bottle of it. I have it downstairs in the kitchen. It's a kind of sweet wine. It's very nice. Is it? Yeah.
我今年夏天、去年夏天去莫奈姆瓦西亚度假了。你尝过胡萝卜吗？我们买了一瓶。我把它放在楼下的厨房里。它是一种甜酒。非常好喝。是吗？对。
There's now a producer in... I should be taking money for this. There's a producer in Mononvasia that is now producing, once again, proper Mononvasium Malmsy wine. Clarence. So there you go. The Clarence vintage.
现在有个生产商在……我应该为此收点广告费。莫奈姆瓦西亚现在有一个生产商，再次开始生产正宗的莫奈姆瓦西亚马姆齐甜酒。克拉伦斯。所以你看。克拉伦斯珍藏版。
Yeah. Well, the fact that in the shop that was owned by, they sort of muttered something about, there was a very famous Englishman who was drowned in it. And I knew the story. So it was a lovely moment. Anyway, you had to be there.
对。好吧，事实上，在那家店里，他们咕哝着说，曾有一个非常著名的英国人被淹死在里面。而我知道这个故事。所以那是一个美好的时刻。总之，你得身临其境才行。
Yeah. Anyway, yes, he's, so that leaves Richard really sort of unchallenged, doesn't it? Yeah. And he's very,
对。总之，是的，他，所以这使得理查德基本上处于无可挑战的地位，不是吗？是的。而且他非常，
he's a very competent administrator. And he's very,'s a very competent administrator uh and he's very he's very pious um and i think all of these are absolutely it's perfectly possible for him to be a competent administrator to be very pious and also when needs be to be incredibly ruthless well because i don't think to be if you want to survive in the game absolutely i don't think that there is any inherent contrast there yeah i agree completely and it's actually 20 or 20th first century back projection to see so many of these people oh he's a good guy he's evil they're all involved in what is a very very frightening
他是一个非常称职的行政管理者。而且他非常、是个非常称职的行政管理者，嗯，而且他非常、他非常虔诚，嗯，我认为所有这些都绝对是完全可能的，他既是一个称职的行政管理者，又非常虔诚，而且在需要的时候也能够极其冷酷无情。嗯，因为我不认为——如果你想在这个游戏中生存下来，完全没错——我不认为这里面有什么内在的冲突。是的，我完全同意，而且把其中许多人看作“哦，他是个好人，他是个恶魔”，这其实是20世纪或21世纪的视角回溯。他们都卷入了一场非常非常可怕、充满风险、危险的生意，而且他们没得选，他们生来就卷入其中，被困在里面。没有什么第四代亨利——我是说他可能算选过，但他们大多数人，你知道的，比方说理查德，他出生在战争的正中央，当他还是个男孩的时候，局势就已经彻底白热化了，他没有真正的办法逃脱，除非他决定当个和尚什么的，或者移民到冰岛。好吧，说到生来就卷入其中，我们当然应该回到——嗯，这个播客的表面主题，也就是塔中的王子们——所以爱德华，你知道的，他曾和他的母亲伊丽莎白·伍德维尔一起在庇护所里，显然当——所以这是当——是的，所以他出来了。一切都很好。
risky dangerous business and they haven't chosen it they've been born into it and they're stuck in it there's no kind of head with the fourth has kind of chosen it i suppose he has but most of them you know richard let's say is is born in the midst of the wars it's it you know it's all kicking off when he was a boy he's he's not no real way of escaping it unless he decided to be a monk or something or to sort of emigrate to iceland well and talking about being born into it of course we should go back to um the ostensible subject of this podcast which are the princes in the tower um so edward you know he'd been in in sanctuary with his mother elizabeth woodville obviously when so this is when yeah so he comes out. All is well.
而爱德华四世显然想把他培养成一个尽可能优秀的继承人。他在1471年成为威尔士亲王，也就是他回归的那一年。然后在1473年，当他三岁的时候，他成为了威尔士及边区委员会的主席。我的意思是，我觉得从威尔士走出来并不需要那么多的经验。好吧，我们所有的威尔士听众都要不高兴了。他的驻地在拉德洛城堡，听过我们“圣诞节十二天”特辑的听众会记得，那是约克家族的一个特定据点。但我也记得那是亚瑟·都铎——
And Edward IV obviously wants to train him up to be as good an heir as he possibly can. And he becomes Prince of Wales in 1471, so the year after his return. And then in 1473, when he is three years old, he becomes president of the Council of Wales and the Marches. I mean, I don't think you need that much experience to go from Wales. Well, there go all our Welsh listeners. And he's based at Ludlow Castle, which listeners to our 12 Days of Christmas episode will remember was a particular Yorkist stronghold. But I also remember the castle where Arthur Tudor,
亨利·都铎的儿子——将要去世的城堡。所以这显然是你必做的常规操作。你把继承人派去，基本上是为了在威尔士、在边区建立你的存在感。但关键是，汤姆，我认为这是一个有趣的迹象，或者说是通往后来悲剧的一步。他派安东尼·伍德维尔陪同他去，就是你刚才提到的那个极其令人印象深刻的人。
Henry Tudor's son, was to die. So this is obviously a standard thing you do. You send your heir to basically establish your presence in Wales, in the marches. But crucially, Tom, I think an interesting sort of straw in the wind or a step towards the tragedy that's going to come later. He sends him with Anthony Woodville, that tremendously impressive person that you talked about earlier.
因为他令人印象深刻。我认为，我认为不仅仅是因为他是一个伍德维尔兄弟，而是因为他是一个很有档次的导师人选，因为他非常有学问，而且他也很擅长把别人从马上撞下来。因为这意味着当他的儿子继承王位时，他将会非常亲近——他理所当然地会非常亲近伍德维尔家族，而伍德维尔家族显然将在随后的任何政权中扮演重要角色。每一个国王都必须分而治之，所以这对于国王来说永远是一个风险——爱德华深知这一点，因为他已经被流放过一次了——你必须有地方诸侯来照顾你王国的各个部分，所以
Because he's impressive. I think, I think not just because he's not just because he's a Woodville brother, but because he is, he's a kind of classy guy to have as your, as your tutor, because he's very, very learned, but he's also very good at knocking people off horses. story because he it means that when his son succeeds him he will be very close he will understandably be very close to the woodvilles and the woodvilles will clearly going to play a significant part in any subsequent regime every every king has to divide and rule so it's always a risk for a king and edward knows this because he's already been sent into exile once that that you have to have regional magnates to look after chunks of your kingdom so
你需要，你知道的，我们在北方的自己人，我们在米德兰兹的自己人，我们在威尔士的自己人，你需要这些；但与此同时，你又承担不起让他们任何一个人建立起权力垄断的后果。所以如果你是一个国王，你就必须创造相互制衡的权力基地。显然，克拉伦斯和理查德作为兄弟，绝对拥有地位和身份，现在他们又被赋予了地方权力基地。伍德维尔家族根本无法与之抗衡。但爱德华通过让他的儿子威尔士亲王由伍德维尔家族的一员抚养长大，我认为他是在非常刻意地将伍德维尔家族培养成对抗他兄弟的一种平衡力量。
you need you know our man in the north our man in the midlands our man in wales you need that but at the same time you can't afford any one of them to build up a monopoly of power so you have to if you're a king create rival power bases bases. Obviously, Clarence and Richard, as brothers, are absolutely, you know, they have rank and status and now they've been given regional power bases. The Woodvilles can't possibly rival that. But by giving his son, the Prince of Wales, to be brought up by one of the Woodvilles, Edward is, I think, quite deliberately trying to build the Woodvilles up as a kind of counterpoint to his brothers.
是的。而且他是在假设自己还能活下去的前提下行事的。这正是我要说的。爱德华大概以为自己能活到55岁左右。你知道的，对于一个中世纪国王来说算是个不错的年龄。可能他还能比那多活10年、20年。所以在某种程度上，我想你会说——我的意思是，他可能会比安东尼·伍德维尔活得还久。他的儿子可能在40岁时继位。但同时，我认为这并不仅仅完全出于犬儒主义。我认为当你查看爱德华四世给安东尼·伍德维尔的训令时，
Yeah. And he's acting on the assumption that he's going to live. That's exactly what I was going to say. Edward presumably thinks he's going to live to the age of 55 or something. You know, decent age for a medieval king. Possibly he could live 10, 20 years longer than that. So in a way, I suppose you would say, I mean, he could outlive Anthony Woodville. His son may succeed when he's 40. But also, I think it's not just entirely down to cynicism. I think when you look at the prescriptions that Edward IV gives to Anthony Woodville,
考虑到爱德华四世本人的性格，这其实相当令人动容。所以他非常非常热衷于让安东尼·伍德维尔在美德和学问中抚养威尔士亲王。是的，我喜欢这一切。伍德维尔写过关于哲学的书，他——是的，他完全有资格这样做——教导他进行体育运动，确保没有任何说脏话的行为，然后到了傍晚，爱德华具体规定，王子的随从们要尽力让他感到快乐和高兴，直到他上床睡觉。我觉得这——我觉得这——我觉得这很有趣，不是吗？爱德华四世并不希望他的儿子像他一样，因为他说：“我希望王室里没有任何人说脏话、
it's rather touching, bearing in mind Edward IV's own character. So he's very, very keen that Anthony Woodville raise the Prince of Wales in virtuous learning. Yes, I love all this. Which, you know, woodville has written books about philosophy he yeah he's well qualified to do that to teach him in sport to ensure that there's no swearing um and then towards evening the prince's attendance edward specifies are to enforce themselves to make him merry and joyous towards his bed i think that is i think that is i think that's interesting isn't it that edward the fourth doesn't want his son to be like him because he says i want no one in the household to be a swearer
争吵、说坏话、赌博成性、寻花问柳或使用下流言语。”是的，这几乎把他自己所有的毛病都排除在外了，这很可能就是他把儿子打发走的原因。但我不认为——我太有亨利八世既视感的平行对比了，因为亨利八世是个非常感性的人，他既冷酷无情，但同时又非常感性，我认为爱德华四世也是这样。每个人总是说他多么平易近人，你知道的，他的徽号是烈日当空，烈日当空。他的座右铭之一就是某种安慰与快乐。他对事情有一种相当玫瑰色的看法，你不觉得吗，爱德华四世？我的意思是，我知道他是个混蛋，他杀人，
brawler backbiter common hazard adulterer or user of words of ribaldry yeah which is everything which basically rules himself out which may well be why he's he's packed him off um but is that i do not think there's a i am so struck by the sort of hem of the eighth parallels because hem of the eighth is a terribly sentiment he's both ruthless but he's also very sentimental and i think edward the fourth is like that too he's everybody always says how affable he is you know his his sign is the sun and splendor the sun in splendor one of his mottos is kind of comfort and joy he's quite a sort of he's got quite a kind of rose tinted view of things don't you think edward the fourth i mean i know he's a bastard and he kills
但显然当他想到自己的儿子时，他希望他的儿子能够——你知道的——不要沾染任何那些脏话之类的东西。不，不，我认为是真的，我认为这——而且事实上进行得很顺利，不是吗？王子的成长看起来绝对一帆风顺。每个人都说第五个爱德华，这个小男孩是个了不起的小家伙。而且他还有一个弟弟。所以，我的意思是，你知道的，爱德华不像亨利八世，他绝对尽到了自己的责任。我的意思是，这其实是最精彩的部分。
people but obviously when you think about his son he wants his son to kind of you know not have anything and no swearing that sort of stuff no i i think that's true i think that's and actually it goes well doesn't it the the The upbringing seems to go absolutely swimmingly. Everybody says the fifth, the little boy is a tremendous little fellow. And he's got a brother. So, I mean, you know, Edward, unlike Henry VIII, has absolutely done his duty. I mean, there's actually the brilliant thing.
当他娶了伊丽莎白·伍德维尔时，他的母亲塞西莉对此勃然大怒，然后爱德华对母亲的回答是：“我们俩都不太可能会绝育。”事实也确实如此。伊丽莎白为爱德华生下了女王理应生下的大量继承人，其中一个当然是威尔士亲王爱德华，但另一个是理查德。是的，理查德出生在什鲁斯伯里，实际上是他的第六个孩子。爱德华的第六个孩子，但他的第二个儿子。
When he married Elizabeth Woodfill and his mother, Cecily, was absolutely furious about it and then Edward's reply to to his mother was to say well neither of us is like to be barren and that absolutely turns out to be the case Elizabeth gives Edward exactly what a queen is supposed to do large number of heirs one of whom is of course is Edward the Prince of Wales, but the other is Richard. Yeah, Richard, who's born in Shrewsbury, who is actually his sixth child. Edward's sixth child, but his second son.
而我们对他的了解几乎为零。嗯，我们知道他在1474年被封为约克公爵，然后在1478年，当他——几岁来着？——五岁时，他结婚了。他结婚了。他结婚了。
And we know virtually nothing about him. Well, we know that he's made Duke of York in 1474, and then in 1478, when he is, what, five? He gets married. He marries. He marries.
他娶了诺福克伯爵夫人。她也是五岁。是的。但同时他很快就成了鳏夫，不是吗？他在七岁左右就丧妻了。是的，所以他效率很高。他过着活跃的生活。他见过了很多世面。
He marries the Countess of Norfolk. He's also five. Yeah. But also he's widowed quite quickly, isn't he? He's widowed by about the age of seven or something. Yeah, so he's packing it in. He's had an active life. He's seen a lot of the world.
没错。他在《黑爵士》第一季里由布莱恩·布莱塞德饰演。是吗？而且，当然，这是一个平行现实，不是吗？这是一个他幸存下来并成为国王的平行现实。是的，就像——是的，是的。而且当然，在这一集的开头由我饰演——是的。你是在把自己比作布莱恩·布莱塞德吗？那里的声音非常不同。我觉得，嗯，我是年轻的理查德，而布莱恩·布莱塞德显然是——另一个……不管怎样，所以这一切——这一切看起来对约克家族来说都进展顺利。约克家族的政权绝对是稳固的。兰开斯特家族
Exactly. He's played by Brian Blessed in the first series of The Blackadder. Is he? And, of course, it's an alternative reality isn't it it's an alternative reality in which he survives and becomes king yeah well like yeah yeah um and of course played by me at the beginning of uh of this episode yeah um are you equating yourself with brian blessed the very different voices there i thought well i'm the young richard and brian blessed is obviously the uh the other one um anyway so all of the all of this it's all looks to be going well for the york for the yorkists they've basically they you know the the rate the yorkist regime is absolutely secure there are the lancastrians
已经被消灭了，唯一可想象的剩余血脉就是都铎家族。你知道的，这个默默无闻的威尔士乡绅娶了一位法国王后。正如你所说，如此默默无闻，如此不可能。根本引不起注意。所以看起来约克家族的政权是绝对稳固的。而爱德华四世是国王的典范。他就是我们一直所说的一切。但问题是，这又有点像他的孙子亨利八世。
have been wiped out the only conceivableivable line left is the Tudors. You know, this obscure Welsh squire who married a French queen. As you say, so obscure and so unlikely. It doesn't register. So it looks as though the Yorkist regime is absolutely secure. And Edward IV is the model of a king. He's everything that we've been saying. But the problem is, again, a bit like his grandson, Henry VIII.
非常像他的孙子。他做得过头了。是的，玩得太疯了。玩得太疯了。所以他……他变得越来越胖，同样像亨利。到了1480年代，即1480年代初，他就像是老太婆装嫩。我的意思是，
Very like his grandson. He overdoes it. Yeah, too much fun. Too much fun. So he's... He gets increasingly fat, again, like Henry. And there's this whole kind of... By the 1480s, the early 148080s he's mutton dressed as lamb i mean
他还在订购所有这些——这话说得有点严厉——这种时髦的青少年时装，但他看起来——我的意思是，他看起来就像一根香肠。人们在看到他时——他就像猫王，不是吗？他是19世纪（编者注：应为20世纪）拉斯维加斯的猫王，被塞进皮衣里，所以他——他一直是那种会暴饮暴食的人。但我的意思是，有记录显示，他们从药剂师那里下了订单。他订购了大量的各种药物。但他还订购了所有这些据说他在吃饭时服用的催吐剂。
he's still ordering all these that's harsh these kind of groovy teenage fashions but he just looks i mean he looks like kind of sausage yeah people kind of when he's elvis isn't he he's elvis in the 19th las vegas squeezed into his leather or his so he's he's he has this he's always been a man for a binge. But I mean, there were records, aren't there, of their sort of orders from apothecaries. And he's ordering an awful lot of kind of drugs. But he's also ordering all these emetics that supposedly he takes during meals.
所以他把它们全塞进嘴里。是的。这样他就可以吃六道菜而不是三道菜之类的。多米尼克，结果好吗？不，不好，汤姆。结果不好。
So he stuffs them all down. Yeah. So that he can have six courses instead of three or whatever. And Dominic, does it turn out well? No, it doesn't, Tom. It doesn't turn out well. down yeah yeah so that he can have six courses instead of three or whatever and dominic does it turn out well no it doesn't tom it doesn't turn out well but but the interesting thing is it's not like people say he's a great balloon he's going to burst at some point people are genuinely shocked when at easter 1483 he falls ill and there's still some nobody really knows what was wrong with him with some people say he had a stroke. Some people say that he had at some point contracted malaria
但有趣的是，并不像人们说的那样“他是个大气球，随时会爆炸”。当他在1483年复活节生病时，人们是真真正正感到震惊的，而且直到现在也没有人真正知道他究竟得了什么病。有人说他中风了。有人说他早年曾感染过疟疾。我们不知道。但无论如何，他发烧了，然后他就死了。我认为这对整个故事至关重要。这就是它与亨利八世之死等事件的不同之处，亨利八世死后也是由一个小孩爱德华六世继位。
earlier in his life. We don't know. But anyway, he catches a fever and he dies. And I think this is absolutely crucial for the story. And this is what makes it different from, let's say, the death of Henry VIII, who also succeeded by a little boy in Edward VI.
一个关键的区别是爱德华四世死得非常快。所以在什么，一周、两周之内？所以人们没有时间去铺平道路，没有时间准备他们的关系网，没有时间计算力量对比。所以他在4月9日去世了，他的两个儿子分别只有12岁和9岁，
A key difference is that Edward IV dies very quickly. So within, what, a week, a couple of weeks? So people haven't had time to prepare the ground, to get their kind of networks ready, to work out the balance of forces. So he dies on the 9th of April, and his two sons are 12 and 9,
麻烦立刻就来了。是的。而且当他去世时，有两个关键人物不在宫廷里。那就是年轻的爱德华五世的两个叔叔。安东尼·伍德维尔和威尔士亲王本人在拉德洛。当然，还有他仅存的叔叔，在北方的格洛斯特的理查德。他在北方。
and immediately you've got problems. Yeah. And there are two key people who are not at court when he dies. And that is the young Edward V's two uncles. So Anthony Woodville in Ludlow with the Prince of Wales himself. And, of course, his surviving uncle, Richard of Gloucester, who is up in the North. Who's up in the North.
他一直在跟苏格兰人打仗，不是吗？所以问题立刻就来了，你知道的，问题被提出来了，爱德华死了。爱德华四世死了。他的儿子还年轻。
He's been fighting the Scots, hasn't he? So that immediately the question comes, you know, the questions raised is, Edward is dead. Edward IV is dead. His son is young.
所有这些不同的约克家族派系将如何去应对这个年轻的国王？我想这是一个我们应该留到明天再回答的问题。哦，这种紧张感，真是个悬念啊，汤姆。
How are all the various Yorkist factions, how are they going to negotiate this youthful king and that I think is a question that we should leave to answer until tomorrow oh the tension it's such a cliffhanger Tom
真不敢相信你会对听众这么做，但他们就喜欢这样。所以我们明天见，届时我们将谈论《塔中的王子》第二季，也就是王子们最终真正住进塔里的那一集。
I can't believe you would do this to the audience but they love it so we will see you tomorrow when we will talk about Princes in the Tower Part 2 when the princes actually will end up in the tower at last
至少我们设法让他们生下来并且活了下来，我的意思是，这总算是一点成就。这就像《项狄传》一样，对吧？整件事情就是这样。所以我们到时候见，拜拜。
at least we've managed to get them born and alive I mean that's something it's like Tristan Shandy isn't it the whole thing so we will see you then bye bye
拜拜。我们回头见。拜拜。拜拜。感谢收听《历史就是这样》。想要收听独家节目、提前解锁、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。
bye We'll see you then. Bye-bye. Bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见，我们到时候见。拜拜。拜拜。感谢收听《历史的余烬》。如需收听独家剧集、提前解锁、免广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社群，请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。